sad and shocked
definitely just like definitely how many
of us felt today learning
mark andre fleury will not be returning
to t-mobile as a vegas golden knight
kevin martin joining us live from the
fortress with the details
on today's big trade tough news for so
many fans
yeah brian you got that right a very
tough day for vegas golden knights fans
the face of the franchise for the first
four seasons of the vegas golden knights
has been traded
to the chicago blackhawks now mark at
the end of the day this trade was all
about money marc-andre fleury was set to
make 7
million dollars next season the
organization instead
wants to use that money to go out and
get other players the nhl has a hard
salary cap
and there are limits on what a team can
spend on players salaries
fleury won the award for top goalie in
the nhl last season
he has been the face of the franchise
and a lot of fans are not happy
about seeing flower go you're not only
disrespecting marc-andre flair you're
disrespecting the fans
and i'm really disappointed right now
mark andre fleury forever
with fleury being a face of the
franchise
they definitely have like stabbed a lot
of the fan base in the back with this
so i kind of they kind of did lose a
little support from me for this
he's had a tremendous impact on our
organization he's had a tremendous
impact
uh on our city so i know for a lot of
people this is a
a day that uh definitely is filled with
sadness and
uh certainly i share all the same
emotions uh
that you do and yet i do feel
you know i'm responsible to try to do
everything i can
to put the best team on the ice
fleury has said he wanted to stay here
for the rest of his career most likely
that would have been one more season
robin leonard who makes 5 million a year
as four years left on his contract
will now be the top goalie going into
camp in september
robin leonard tweeting there is not many
people
i've met or a player with respect as
much
as flower 100 percent hall of fame guy
that i will miss understandably a very
tough day for vegas golden knights fan
flower was endearing he was engaging he
was a huge
locker room asset with his teammates and
coaches
but tonight he is a chicago blackhawk
reporting live outside a t-mobile arena
kevin martin 8 sports now
kevin thank you on twitter fans weighing
in rachel holt saying you can say
goodbye to quite a few fans you
lose i will never support a team that
does something like this
and lindsay christensen says flurry
we will miss you you are the light
during the darkest days of vegas
and you were the smile to everyone
please do what is right for you because
you deserve it